mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
die autokinos booming wieder in
deutschland zumindest filme konzerte ja
sogar gottesdienste alles ist möglich im
auto ob mit oder ohne armut und
garantiert corona frei das wollen wir
auch fanden wir und haben 1 gefunden
in dietikon wir kommen aus dem
kulturplatz also ich liebe das kino und
ich kann es kaum erwarten bis die
kinosäle endlich wieder aufgehen
dementsprechend elektrisiert war ich von
der idee des autokinos jeder für sich
und doch alle zusammen einen film
schauen in diesen doch eher schwierigen
zeiten doch bloß wo sind sie denn die
autokinos in corona zeiten wir haben die
halbe schweiz abgesucht und jetzt sind
wir doch noch fündig geworden einsteigen
wir nehmen sie mit
[Musik]
unsere regeln in kronau tag die lockern
sich weiter und parallel dazu schauen
sie auch unser verhältnis zu den
tatsachen zu lockern abstruse
verschwörungstheorien schießen in diesen
tagen und wochen ins kraut
wir menschen brauchen offensichtlich
geschichten um die tatsachen irgendwie
begreifbar zu machen auch wenn diese
geschichten noch so gut es sind die
demonstrierenden nennen es corona
mahnwachen
ihr protest richtet sich gegen
angebliche polizeiwillkür
gegen vermeintliche geheime pläne die
grundrechte auszuhebeln cupid 19 das ist
für einige corona rebellen nur ein
harmloses virus
einige glauben nachdem lockdown an
alternative wahrheiten
das virus harmlos dahinter stecke etwas
ganz anderes solche und ähnliche
geschichten grassieren auf
demonstrationen und im netz krisenzeiten
sind der ideale nährboden für
verschwörungstheorien weiß auch der
literaturwissenschaftler thomas strässle
der sich mit den geschichten hinter
falsch nachrichten beschäftigt hat in
verschwörungstheorie muss eben leer
stellungsfehler
also wenn sie es war bild hand wo
irgendwo erbes ungeklärt ist der
ingenieur ist ihre wo genau die die
lehrer stellen was genau wie das in
vakuum innen passt genau geeignet
crosslauf wieder schließen
das momentane sinn vakuum der krise
füllen mehrere websites in der schweiz
die ihre resultat aus alternativen
wahrheiten über die korona pandemie
ableiten
diese extreme ausnahmezustand muss in
frage gestellt werden weil immer mehr
ungereimtheiten bezüglich undeklarierten
experten manipulativen statistiken und
propaganda kampagne die mit unseren
steuern bezahlte bekannte
heraufbeschworen werden theorien wie
corona sei nur darum eine weltweite
zwangsimpfung zu legitimieren
oder das virus eine bio waffe aus einem
chinesischen labor vor allem aber werden
mächtige männer wie bill gates und die
pharmaindustrie als ursache hinter der
pandemie vermutet die verschwörung
lauert überall
unsichtbare vereinzelt dem grundner oder
und dem moment irgendwie sichtbar machen
denn mal irgendwo ordner und der nächste
schritt relativ nahe liegend dass man
seit es gibt irgendein blauen dahinter
es geht ihnen die gute hindern und dann
kann man sich auf zurück immer auch er
wird sich besonders gut eignen und was
für den absichten die dahinter steht um
zu baut man quasi der große
erzählerische parameter definiert kamera
fabuliere
heftig fabuliert wird auch in
deutschland wo die organisatoren der
anti corona demonstrationen neue
feindbilder schaffen
corona panik ist eine inszenierung
sie ist ein betrüger trick es ist
höchste zeit dass wir verstehen dass wir
inmitten eines weltweiten und mafiösen
verbrechens sind
das haben wir eine chance
ich werde mit diesen ärger erst aufhören
wenn diese regierung mit diesen
politikern wenn die in einem krone
ausschuss sitzen und sich verantworten
müssen weil sie ruinieren unser land
kein gutes von toni unrichtig
ordentliche bösewicht in der bucht immer
irgendein figur zumindest hauptantrieb
wende groß gewachsene bösewicht ist so
funktioniert drei erzählen und aus
übernahmen verschwörungstheorien
wir erleben momentan mit mancher
ungewissheit und grundrechte wie zum
beispiel das versammlungsrecht sind
eingeschränkt doch die verschwörung
hinter dem virus hilft uns nicht die
situation zu meistern
sie verhindert nur den dialog ich glaube
es bremst uhr bereits und machen nicht
dass man jetzt quasi dass das abkommen
ist entstanden ist mit irgendetwas und
fülle
wo zwar völlig für gewisse plausibel ist
aber letztlich dazu führt dass raps
verhängt übrigens wussten sie dass sich
bei asterix in italien einer der
römischen gegner corona virus nennt
einigen verschwörungstheoretikern ein
beweis dass corona schon lange ein
abgekartetes spiel war kaum zu glauben
[Musik]
aber auch die zu- und auf der moment für
mich eigentlich los war und jetzt gibt
es dann nur achter bis zum intimen
aufsteller tun zu haben
[Musik]
ja das im red openpr parkplatz endlich
clean water act wie man gesehen dass
muss nur noch die dunkelwerden der
beamer ist am gericht ein riese beamer
wahnsinn und die glut vom casino oder
verkauf und kauf aber liegen zwei und ab
der 8 nach wir als pilot über gekürten
als herzog als notfall wo man darf sie
nicht benutzen
all die menschen die ihrem auto bliebe
das sind chor ohne regen
[Musik]
wir haben noch zeit bis zum film
startseite für unseren schwerpunkt
dieser woche es gibt profilierte stimmen
die befürchten dass die korona krise zu
einem backlash zwischen den
geschlechtern führt dass also die
vergangenen wochen und monate alte
rollenmuster neu zementieren
ob das tatsächlich so ist meine kollegin
sibylle maldini hat sich umgehört
[Musik]
dominique lüdi ist schauspielerin und
dreifache mutter
sie und ihr mann auch freischaffender
künstler haben mit dem lockdown aufträge
verloren aber die grundkosten sind
gedeckt schule zugegangen sie nicht mit
das sehr verschreckt und das wichtigste
ist jetzt der mikrokosmos ich unsere
familie und das ganze politiker die
krise als chance
in vielen haushalten hat die
ausnahmesituation offengelegt und
deutlich gemacht wie viel haus und
sogenannte care arbeitet sich kümmern
und pflegen täglich hier anfallen
[Musik]
gemeinsam die messe also kindern wird
gemacht backe kocht wissen die sache
irgendwie anders gegangen und ich glaube
ich weiß aber dass nicht alle sondern
luxuriöse situation kommen wir jetzt von
mir das partnerschaftlich möglich da
hält an
in der tat die gleichberechtigte
arbeitsteilung bleibt wohl eher ausnahme
laut unicef leisten frauen weltweit
dreimal so viel unbezahlte mehrarbeit
und diese steigt in einer pandemie
situation exponentiell an
und damit doppelt und dreifach
belastungen von frauen krisen verstärken
ungleichheiten auch im
geschlechterverhältnis sagt sie tina
beuchler gender forscherin an der
universität bern und seine familie
befürchtet karriereknicks ein
zementierung in alte rollenmuster und
einen längerfristigen einbruch in der
frauenerwerbsquote start von der dunlop
down und ich habe gut vorstellen sowie
sport und das war richtig dass man das
beobachter ein großteil der
systemrelevanten berufe wird vom
weiblichen teil der bevölkerung
geleistet
frauen die sich risiken aussetzen und
nicht entsprechend bezahlte arbeit
leisten sie sind die viel beklatschten
heldinnen der krise doch gehen
möglicherweise als verliererinnen daraus
hervor erstens mal werd ich hoffe dass
jetzt die große die erhöht die
sichtbarkeit von relevanz von den frauen
der tk das aber die pflege im
detailhandel dass es wirklich lange
fertig dazu führt dass man zutaten
schritte du wirklich die arbeiter vor
was schätze auch finanziell über der
arbeitsbedingungen hart aber ich muss
leider meint mit keyboard und das hot
dogs folge die stimmen die mit der coop
19 pandemie auch eine krise der frauen
angebrochen sehen werden zunehmend
lauter
auch marlies haller von den schweizer
frauenhäusern sorgt sich die zahl der
anfragen nach hilfe bei häuslicher
gewalt ist zwar noch stabil doch mit
isolation und controlling sowie so und
jetzt in locktow wert liegt der helm und
zwar oft familien also sprich wenn der
reifen welt froh ohne telefoniere oder
nicht online abos oder nicht
seitdem lockt ein sind in großbritannien
dreimal so viele frauen zu hause getötet
worden 30 prozent mehr häusliche gewalt
verzeichnet frankreich 20 prozent mehr
anrufe beim hilfe telefon in deutschland
auch die schweiz ist auf eine zunahme
vorbereitet flavia kleiner initianten
der frauenpolitik kampagne helvetia ruft
auch für sie birgt die krise gefahren in
der entwicklung der gleichstellung die
letzte woche immer man sich zeitig
aufgeschlagen haben hat mir ein anderem
erklärt was geht ab gewalt es gibt sogar
star virologe moment sind die
überwiegend männliche expertise in der
öffentlichkeit mitten in einer krise von
globaler dimension wird nachhaltig
schlange da noch starke führung und es
ist hierzulande sehr stark korrodiert
mit konzept wie vernunft rationalität
aber hat die wissenschaft oder auch
sicherheit beschützt sie wird oft im
moment ihnen dafür beim nude von vater
staat hier befürchtet muss der schütze
für ihn fixieren zu einer deutlichen
erhöhung der infektions
wahrscheinlichkeit nachricht wenn es um
dem asset manager und dass es wirklich
ein herber rückschlag für die bemühungen
monika hecker zuversichtlich stellung
man weiß halt aus der geschichte
weiteres vergangene krise und ich hatte
ganz konkret auf die ölkrise und der
70er jahre war wirtschaftlich so
schwierig sie sind dass man damit ein
ist arbeitslosigkeit wo entstanden ist
einerseits exportiert hat in der wir die
italienische gastarbeiter einfach wieder
nach italien schickte und andere sieht
frauen wieder die unbezahlte arbeit die
teamarbeit und so eigentlich die
arbeitslosenzahl abgewartet hat und uns
ist es sehr wichtig den event ganz will
kann wann etwas brauche wieder so
rückschritt erlahmen der liga möchte im
gegenteil dafür sorgen dass er frauen
mit diskutieren und sich an die bringen
damit was nun passieren
mehr denn je müssen frauen jetzt in die
politik in der sich anbahnenden
wirtschaftskrise
wenn entschieden wird welche bereiche
der gesellschaft wie unterstützt werden
die effekte der korona krise verlangen
aus feministischer perspektive ein sehr
genaues beobachten die entwicklungen und
ein wahrnehmen der chancen
[Musik]
wir haben das ist das erste autokino
so haben das passt
[Musik]
im moment sind okay ich bleibe wird auf
distanz gehört und wie viel waage sind
die tickets im verkauf besser sein und
landesliga schafft auch cloud im nach
vorn mit
und dann bin ja fdp vize und das so
persönlich wie lange wir wissen wenn es
so aus sich zum teil homeschooling ja
genau jetzt
identrust haben noch zum reformator ja
einiges und den iren ja gerne die
passion täters wurde und das spiel so
stelle die für dennis und die ganze
zweck war bis jetzt der moment
und dann ja auch gern zu ihm zu den
herren doch genau jedes projekt braucht
der audi hat sie losgelöst die dem
vorstand kriesel ihn war der große
beamer bis jetzt sind wenn ihre
top-teams vodafone steuer würde so sagen
genauso wie viel hätte man da jetzt zum
samstag eine realisierung so häufig
scott stuber dieser firma b 5 bis 6
es sind zwei wochen und es läuft extrem
gut aber es gibt leider schlecht die
neugier was ist passiert
lüttich im blickpunkt und den kanton hat
jetzt sich über gemeint gesetzt wo mehr
bewegung gehört und dann seien leute ja
wenn man das teil der absage was ist der
grund
allgemeines veranstaltungs verbot obwohl
ich selber gesehen grundsätzlich kein
problem geben ganze weile beschäftigen
ich bin von konturen und darfst du dich
ja es ist okay jetzt da sie hat das
außenpolitik stehen jetzt noch zwei
wochen auch so
der lohn das auto verbessert
[Musik]
das müssen wir schauen dass wir noch den
original ton des films bekommen auf 88,1
auf ukw ist die frequenz des films ja
mitten in der korona krise gibt die
berner rapperin steff la cheffe ihr
neues album heraus es heißt ps
doppelpunkt und wir wissen ja dass sich
im post scriptum eines briefes oftmals
die hauptbotschaft versteckt mit corona
hat dieses album eden fast nix am hut es
wurde dafür produziert trotzdem wollten
wir von steff la cheffe wissen wie sie
denn für sie klingt die krise so wie sie
findet
feindliches loslassen die gegenwart
genießen das ist steff la cheffe
persönliches credo im spiel die energie
der sonne kraft die das wurde gut tut
die 33 jährige musikerin und ihr
produktionsteam können in der krise
gelassen bleiben denn ihr viertes werk
ps doppelpunkt war vor der korona zeit
entstanden und eigentlich nur als mini
album mit fünf songs gedacht es wuchs
ich erst während der aufnahmen zum album
aus darin waren weder plattentaufe noch
tour geplant die chefin musste somit
auch nichts absagen unter der virus alle
zu einer auszeit zwang lernte auch sie
sich zu entspannen
wegen der märkte sieht den ganzen körper
mit niveau befinde mich glücklicher
wohlbefinden stärkt damit die mediziner
oder tanne wieso realisiert hsg 20.30
mal pause zu gönnen um aussitzen und
maus schlafen und aber ohne schlechte
leistungen erfolg zählten für in ihrem
leben schon mit 13 jahren fing sie an zu
boxen und wurde man höre
vize-weltmeisterin auch als rapperin
setzte sie sich durch mit scharfsinn
schaden und selbstvertrauen
mit dem hit harnik kam für staff 2013
der grosserfolg doch dann folgte die
persönliche krise
hier wurde alles zu viel der bbu der
rummel um ihre person der druck
[Musik]
platz ist einfach riesig sie und waren
sehr verliebt war daran ohne hahne und
und mitreden und mit dem jetta und es
witzig sie zum diese stimmen verstummen
damit dem mini andere stimmen
nach vier jahren pause kehrte sie 2018
mit dem album herzschrittmacher rind
zurück sie öffnete ihr herz sank von
unerfüllter liebe trauer und sehnsucht
[Musik]
doch es war noch nicht alles gesagt mit
dem neuen album ps doppelpunkt stellte
sich nochmals ihren wunden auch solchen
aus der kindheit steff la cheffe alias
stefanie peter wuchs mit zwei brüdern in
einer zweizimmerwohnung auf ihre
alleinerziehende mutter musste sich am
existenzminimum durchschlag
papiere von kuka ich schaue nicht nur
schneller fährt der krise geschafft zu
sorgen
ja sie wird auch finanziell knapp sei
aber dass höhere libyen fuß und wichtig
oder für das ringen auf dem neuen album
rappt und singt sie sich nun endgültig
reif anhalten verletzungen von
unerfüllten liebesbeziehung von
abhängigkeiten und gibt der wut darüber
raum sucht zu springen und so für die
technik und akzeptanz und die wiener
markt und selbsterkenntnis und achim
humor vergangen und die akzeptanz und
eigentlich
[Musik]
dafür dauert die messe aber ich liebe
die zu einer neuen liebe das geld
[Musik]
der nachtrag wird zum aufbruch mit einem
neuen album das überzeugt ist wieder die
chefin wir uns hier draußen könnte man
nicht meinen mann ist in einem kino
sozusagen denn den ton können wir
natürlich nicht dafür hören wir leider
die baustelle hier drüben wir leben ja
in meiner finden in solothurn immer die
literaturtage statt und ja sie finden
auch in diesem jahr statt nur leider
nicht real sondern lediglich online ohne
gemütliches zusammensein aber eine
preisträgerin gibt es natürlich auch
dieses jahr
es ist die österreichische
schriftstellerin monika helfer wir
stellen ihnen die preisträgerin vor der
bregenzerwald ländliche idylle pur
doch hinter der schönheit der landschaft
hat die literatur immer wieder die
starren konventionen des dorflebens
sichtbar gemacht
so auch monika helfer in ihrem roman
bagage ein familienroman mit einer
familie die sehr anders ist haben dass
sein verträgt sich überhaupt nirgends
nur in der stadt fällt es nicht auf der
kanzler kann es auch vorkommen dass man
es originell findet aber auf dem land
ist es schon schwierig mal einfach so
eine vorstellung wie es sein sollte und
wenn einer davon ab berichten dann es
ist endlich mag man es nicht in ihrem
neuen roman erzählt monika helfer genau
davon vom anderssein auf dem land im
zentrum steht eine familie die von allen
abschätzig die bagage genannt wird
es ist die zeit kurz vor ausbruch des
ersten weltkrieges am gesellschaftlichen
rand eines kleinen bergdorfs im
bregenzerwald leben josef und maria
moßbrucker mit ihren kindern
ihre extreme armut und die dubiosen
geschäften des vaters machen die familie
zu außenseitern
und das ausgerechnet die mutter mit
einer atemberaubenden schönheit gesegnet
ist passt der dorfgemeinschaft schon gar
nicht ich denke mir auf dem dorf wo
alles so eng ist und so kleines da fällt
es auf und da kommt durch neider von
missgunst
schon bald wird der vater die front
gerufen
die mutter bleibt mit den kleinen kinder
zurück es dauert nicht lange bis es in
der gerüchteküche zu brodeln beginnt
denn die schöne maria erwartet das
nächste kind das ist gezeugt wurde
während josef auf fronturlaub war will
niemand im dorf glauben
angeführt vom fahrer wird die familie
von der gemeinde endgültig zu
ausgestoßenen erklärt das kind in marias
bauch ist die mutter von monika helfer
die bagage ist auch ein roman über die
eigene familiengeschichte
auch wenn er ein stück literatur bleibt
ich möchte einfach dass im roman ist es
sehr viel fiktion drin und sind auch
sachen manchmal geht's mit einem durch
beim schreiben auch mit meiner tante die
ich befragt habe ging es ständig durch
und die hat auch sachen erzählt die sie
glaube ich im moment erfunden hat
vorarlberg hat monika helfer nie länger
verlassen
mit ihrem mann dem schriftsteller
michael köhlmeier wohnt sie in hohenems
ihre großeltern hat monika helfer nie
kennengelernt
fotos gibt es keine eines der wenigen
erbstücke ist ein buch in dem die
großmutter stoffmuster gesammelt hat die
arbeit an dem roman war für die autorin
auch wie das zusammennähen der
erinnerungsfetzen ihrer onkel und tanten
das sind fesselnde das ganze die
geschichte besteht aus fetzen
die vergleiche sind einfach gut und
richtig dass stoff also es ist einfach
ein material mit denen man arbeitet wir
aus texten steht auch ein stoff also das
ist etwas nützt es entsteht etwas
nützliches wenn ich was nähe dann ist
das etwas was ich dann brauchen kann und
das hofft man bei einem text auch
schreibt beim text hofft man auch dass
er anklang findet dass man die brauchen
können dass er nicht für die katz
die erinnerung muss als heilloses
durcheinander gesehen werden heißt es in
einer stelle im roman
erst wenn man ein drama daraus macht
herrscht ordnung
wenn sie noch mehr zu den solothurner
literaturtagen erfahren möchten dann
lege ich ihnen den sf online service zu
diesem thema ans herz dort können sie
auch mir über monika helfer erfahren
und noch ein hinweis in eigener sache am
23 mai können sie ein kulturplatz extra
sehen partie basler alleine im museum
die satiriker in hat während des
lockouts das landesmuseum zürich besucht
und hat dort auch erfahren was das
klosterleben mit fifty shades of grey zu
tun hat und wir hoffen jetzt natürlich
dass das hier heute abend in dietlikon
nicht der letzte auto kinofilm war
gleich jetzt geht's weiter mit der
britischen serie bodyguard bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos